whether you're packing your carry-on or
loading up the RV you need more than a
neck pillow and reading material for
your trip but we've got you covered so
all that's left to do is grab a suitcase
and some shades or a parka your call if
you're going to be hitting the road or
flying in air B&B and hotel tonight are
great options for finding lodgings be it
last-minute accommodations or planning
in advance you can find super unique
homes or meet your host if you want to
share a home with Airbnb
and hotel tonight can hook you up with
open rooms at cheaper prices for
roadtrippers GasBuddy is a necessity
because simply put you don't want to
find yourself on empty and unknown
places I exit can solve similar woes but
also tells you if there are other
worthwhile stops along the freeway and
road trippers can also point out coal
pit stops as well as let you save
locations to go back to later because
you cannot miss the world's oldest chair
museum off exit 23 for fliers download
TripIt or TripCase both apps show you
all the basic info you need to get on
your flight and even if you don't buy
first class you can lay over like a boss
with lounge buddy you can find out which
fancy airport lounges have one-time fees
and pay for them directly from the app
if none are available the app's
consolation prize is that as a pocket
friendly map of all the amenities
available to regular people and for
planning purposes download hopper so you
can keep ahead of airfare predictions no
matter how you're getting to wherever it
is you're going you'll need Google Maps
sure it's been around forever but the
apps latest features make it even better
for travelers real time detours more
locations you can explore around and
consistently smarter turn-by-turn
directions and arrival predictions make
it a standby for your trips because your
vacation is only fun once you get to it